the death toll continues to rise in the
conflict between
israel and hamas militants overnight a
bomb from an israeli air raid struck a
residential building in gaza killing at
least
10 people including children it's the
deadliest
single strike so far in this most recent
conflict
meanwhile hamas militants launched
hundreds of rockets towards israel
some hitting residential areas at least
139 people have been killed in gaza
since monday
while in israel at least seven people
have died the conflict has now
also spread to the larger palestinian
territory the west bank
in an instant a six-story building is
reduced to rubble
all throughout the day and into the
night
explosions reverberated through gaza
city as israel intensified its onslaught
against hamas
as the conflict escalates hour by hour
gazans are fleeing their homes with
whatever they can carry
some have come to this school run by the
u.n in search of a safe place
we were planning to leave during the
night but drones and jets kept bombing
us
at dawn we started moving and ran to the
schools
our children were screaming they wanted
to get away
when we woke up we found everything
behind us destroyed
there's nothing left
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and many israelis too are living in fear
just north of gaza the city of ashkelon
has been hit repeatedly by hamas rockets
it has been very stressful but we are
following the government's instructions
we have faith in the army and our
creator
gaza is not israel's only front in an
intensifying conflict
in the west bank tensions hit new highs
as palestinians exchanged rocks
and gunfire with israeli soldiers for
the first time this week
palestinians died in numbers on the
streets of the territory
the united states has sent a diplomat to
try and broker a ceasefire between
israel and hamas but as flames and
fighting
spread across the holy land peace seems
like a distant prospect
[Music]
i'm joined now by journalist hasan
balusha in gaza city
hasn't thanks for joining us i
understand you didn't get much sleep
last night because of those bombardments
what's the situation like there in gaza
this morning
today is the sixth day of of of the
confrontation
or if you want to call it a war um the
ongoing of bombardment
uh overnight in the morning uh more
people
left their houses especially from the
the border areas in the north and and
the east and went to the underwater
schools where they
to shelter honor one house that they
opened
some of the schools to to for for those
people to stay in
um the the bombardment off
of um of a house overnight in the shawty
refugee camp west of gaza
city where at least 10 10 10 people were
killed
uh most of them were care where were
were kids
and and still you know like the anger
among the palestinians and some rockets
are
launched from gaza toward the israeli
cities
when you talk to people on the ground
there do you get the sense that
there's continued support for hamas in
the face of the
heavy civilian price
well um as the the ongoing of the
israeli strikes and more
more victims on the ground there is like
a huge anger
among palestinians and they ask for uh
for revenge
but still in the same time people are
seeking and asking and wondering about
when the the ceasefire will be restored
and when
um the life will return to the to the
regular time
so we are talking about like dividing
yeah we are talking about the divide of
among the palestinians
some some are asking for the continuous
of this uh
of this confrontation and some asking
for you know like for ceasefire and and
and getting calm are people coping with
the bombardments it must be terrifying i
i
yeah i mean is there a huge amount of
fear in the city
definitely it's terrifying it's the the
least word that
could be said uh if you if you talk to
the people on the ground
if you watch the the social media
platforms uh always talking about the
fear especially among kids and women
and even men men are talking about that
they they fear
the the strikes and they're trying to
calm down their their kids and
their children uh uh it's it's not easy
time war
is like it's it's horrible everywhere in
gaza experienced
uh many confrontations and many wars
before within the
10 years we are talking about four wars
it's not easy to
to cope with that definitely kids are
traumatized
um afterwards when this all of this over
many many reports and many many many
issues will be raised up
um you know about that trauma and and
the effect of this uh
um you know strikes and ongoing
confrontation
and you speak about the the yeah exactly
that the ongoing
conflict in this region how does this
conflict that's flared up
this time compare with more other recent
conflicts in the in the area
well if we compare with 2014
war i mean still we are in the sixth day
uh
um you know of 2014 uh lasted for
50 today at least this time is very
intense
we are talking about like intense
bombardment and it's the same uh
way of the how israeli army targeted
uh um targets in uh across the gaza
strip
um i can't compare if we talk about the
numbers
still we are less than the previous war
but uh it is if we continued as that
it's i think the number would might be
up and and more than the previous times
all right journalist hazard volusia
speaking to us from gaza city many
thanks for the analysis
welcome dw reporter shaunie rosanas has
reported extensively on the region and
is following this latest conflict
for us charlie thanks for coming in
things still clearly very
tense in the region looked to be getting
tenser
what happened overnight what did we see
playing out well as you're saying
it's still very sensitive tense um tense
situation we need to
watch out when we're talking about we're
talking about three different scenes of
course
separate and intertwined at the same
time so we have
the gaza border israel gaza clashes
we've seen air raids we've seen bombing
this night was extremely
um deadly uh with families we've seen in
the ashati
refugee camp a family of five children
six children sorry
and their mothers both of them um
hit by israeli bombs so this is
happening on one front
we have the internal israeli clashes
that are going on they will go on today
as well today it's not but days the day
these palestinians mention
and commemorate their catastrophe in the
founding of the state of israel
and the third front is what we're seeing
um you know
the connected to the second one is the
internal stripes and also the one
in the west bank you know we see
palestinians there led by
fatah forces that are also um
commemorating the nakba day
and that is also bringing a lot of
hypersensitivity today to the region
yeah seriously a complex issue obviously
that can't be
overstated what are the chances we'll
see a ceasefire anytime soon
well actually not too bad it seems like
the arrival of the american envoy and
the ameri and the egyptian
um mediator um efforts are paying off so
far if we were
listening tuning in very carefully to
some of the statements we're seeing
from leadership on both sides we realize
they want to de-escalate
they're looking for the way out nobody
wants to admit defeat nobody wants to
seem the weak and the one interested
more
in the escalation or in a ceasefire but
um
the next few 24 hours i would say will
probably be crucial in getting this
breakthrough and we might be seeing
things winding down finally
so calls for calm and this sort of
international diplomacy
you're talking about we're seeing the
the u.n security council be meeting
tomorrow how important
is that international diplomacy in terms
of this conflict it's crucial it's
vital we have you know hamas and israel
do not have direct talks never had
so if we want to get these two sides to
agree on something we need a third party
mediator
either the americans or maybe sometimes
the use of european forces definitely
egyptians are very effective in that
and we would need that international
community's pressure in order to bring
both sides
down from the high you know letter that
they're climbing into
um ceasefire into de-escalating into
normalcy
which is always tense but at least quite
peaceful and not as harmful for the
civilians
this of course isn't the first time
we've seen conflict in the region it's
no doubt not going to be the last uh can
you put it in context for us
how serious is this conflict when
compared to
other ones in recent years it's quite
serious we've seen hamas being far more
effective more strategically operating
than we've seen before israeli forces
were quite surprised with that and we
need to keep in mind what we're seeing
here also is quite different in the use
of civil
um of the civilians into this war
they're always you know in the middle
east it's always like that they're
always unfortunately
um civilians part of the war but in this
war in particular what we've seen
israel strategically doing is aiming to
the highest
sky scrapers of the residential areas of
gaza
from the beginning trying to put
pressure on hamas through
civil society's suffering and we've seen
gaza rockets rocket you know going
directly into the heart
of israeli cities injury you know having
seven casualties on the israeli side of
course the proportions in numbers is
nothing you know is unbelievable the
disproportion is unbelievable but at the
same time what we're seeing
is quite big achievements for hamas
seven um
seven casualties on the israeli side is
a lot for hamas and they know that which
is partially why they want to
finish this and bring this down because
they cannot
gain much more they know that right
shani
thank you very much hani rosano's dw
reporter
several thousand people in the
australian city of sydney have marked
the palestinian national day with a
protest against israel's attacks on gaza
demonstrators gathered at sydney town
hall and marched through the streets
carrying palestinian flags and chanting
slogans condemning israel
there was also a smaller protest in
melbourne nakba
day commemorates the displacement of
hundreds of thousands of palestinian
arabs
during the first arab israeli war that
conflict began on this day more than
seven decades ago here's a look
when britain officially withdrew from
palestine in may 1948
jewish leaders announced the creation of
a new state to be known as israel
to many palestinians though the day is
known as nakba
also called the palestinian catastrophe
what followed was a bloody conflict
between arab states and israel
and for palestinians a memory of
displacement never forgotten
for them nakba is a day rooted in
historical tragedy
but its symbolism is still felt strongly
today
with the fight for statehood still
ongoing
many palestinians hope by continuing to
assert their culture
it will keep the collective sense of
nationhood alive and potentially
undo the nakba the day is normally
marked with demonstrations
not just in the palestinian territories
but all over the world
at times the events have turned into
confrontations with israeli security
forces
the recent unrest sparked by the
potential eviction of palestinians from
their homes by israeli authorities
will add more fuel to the fire for those
commemorating this
day
meanwhile a vigil against anti-semitism
has been held in girls and cursion in
western germany
earlier this week demonstrators shouted
anti-jewish slogans outside the city
synagogue
but on friday supporters rallied in
solidarity with jewish communities
police estimate around 300 people took
part a spokesperson for chancellor
angela merkel said germany will not
tolerate
anti-semitic protests while peaceful
protests against
israel's policies were allowed some of
those took place in other german cities
such as berlin
you